[Music]
all right we're on the eighth episode of
strategy podcast we're here with Jai
Kisan who's the co-founder and CEO of
movement watches Jake movement is an
accessories company that sells fashion
items that shouldn't break the bank is
that a good way to describe it or is
that bad way to describe it no that's a
great way to describe it we've evolved
since - you know we started with watches
we start with six watches at our core
price anywhere between 95 and hundred
dollars kind of comparable to those 300
the 500 dollar price point watches and
then you know the goal was to continue
to build a lifestyle brand and you know
grow into other accessories so now we
have everything from watches men's
women's to sunglasses to jewelry and one
of our most popular products as of late
is actually our blue light blocking ever
school buses everyone stop in front of
their screens all day and I think a lot
of people least me I had some trouble
you know falling asleep or sleeping in
because I'm staring at screens all day
we have nothing else to do and these
truly fill they filter out this is kind
of a what you call it is me selling a
little bit but like this is a little
shameless but shameless plug but it is
the cool thing about him is like
everyone has it the device on their
screen or has an option on their screen
to block it but it actually distorts the
color so for us it filters the color so
if you shine blue light in it just
blocks it and filters it so graphic
designers or gamers whatever it is like
you're able to continue to you know do
what you do without affecting kind of
your civvie powders but anyways that's
that's been blowing up for us right now
so and the goal is is to clean it to
continue to branch out into other
accessories and really be a truly a
lifestyle brand who bought like who buys
the bula except I feel like you know
whatever I talk to people from LA I'm
just like and he's telling you about
stuff and I'm like everything you just
said is very la when I talked to Nick
who's a mutual friend of ours who runs
thrive market you know he's like yeah
I'm taking
beehive you know pollen shots yeah it's
a blue light blocker la or am I just
missing I think it might have started as
la it was kind of like something people
like to wear and be fashioned for it
even if they didn't have prescription
eyewear but I think given the world we
live in today its accelerated the need
for them and and and truly there's a
there is a benefit to it I mean I was
you know there's proof there's there's
data backing it so I think what maybe
was somewhat of a fashion trend has now
turned into a real utility that is
helpful yeah I live in LA you know oh
wow so maybe it is LA I don't know but
it's doing well for us I think around
the nation in globally so gotcha okay
let's get started with like the
beginning of movement watches would love
to start like I know you guys launched
on IndieGoGo but even taking a step back
from that you know you're the youngest
e-commerce entrepreneur that's super
successful that I've ever met before you
started movement watches you dropped out
of college you were 20 I already dropped
out of college in the year $20,000 in
debt and then you decided to start
watches is that right yeah debt so debt
was to partially credit card debt so I
wasn't about I think it was like six
seven thousand dollars a credit card
debt funding my lifestyle more so and
movement partially like I was still in
college and I had it stopped working at
the time to put all my energy in the
movement and so I was in debt to you
know I had eighteen months of like
interest-free credit card debt so I
maxed those those out for samples and
everything else and then well you know
as well I had received money from kind
of family and friends for a previous
business that just ended up crashing and
burning it was it was doing well at it's
at its peak yeah I had I needed some
capital continue to kind of grow it and
then yeah left me in kind of a place of
you know I don't think I ever some of
the money came from my parents so I've
definitely return that money since hood
but yeah it was it was largely kind of
credit card and family and friends with
you so that's so quick I feel like you
rarely hear about
had a success that you've had and
actually stood like you know
legitimately you have a story about
credit card debt usually it's all these
like guys who sort of had you know who
had like dads we're millionaires and
sort of like we're able to fund their
own success for the money because they
had all these amazing connections you
built movement or you started movement
watches actually swiping your own
critical yeah being like yeah I need to
pay for samples yeah
from me to it was like back against the
wall it's insane yeah your back
is against them I mean like you chose to
make your back against the wall like
you're swiping the credit card ordering
samples of watches yeah because and
you're like giving up your work
opportunities and indeed I'm dropping
out of college from this business you
chose to put yourself on your back
against as well yeah yeah that's a lot
of it's all it's all you have
this starting off right like for me my
dad you know had a business was was you
know kind of middle-class and and but
during the last you know recession that
we were in completely business went out
when you know the closes doors after 20
years and lay off his employees etc and
ran through you know their savings so I
saw financial stress from them I was
supporting myself in college but grand I
had kind of planned on dropping out
regardless I wasn't doing much in
college because I had my previous
business before movement that I was
hoping was gonna be you know the big
winner and then when that went under it
was kind of like okay I have an
opportunity to fund another business
using my credit card you know that I
currently have let me let me go big and
honestly my mentality and maybe it was a
little overdramatic but or maybe not it
was I'll go get I'll go work anywhere if
this doesn't work out I'll go pay this
off but like and I think people who have
their back against the wall typically
end up succeeding because it's sometimes
it takes that to like really figure it
out and grind and put in the extra
energy and you may try tentative as you
know you may try 10 different dings and
only one works out but like that one
thing may be the difference so yeah give
me a poor and hungry person in any day
of the week versus like a rich server
grant like 400 person who's gonna want
to like succeed and has a lot more like
at stake basically yeah
but like it's crazy that you're like I
funded my business on a credit card
like everyone's like founded by business
with the millions of dollars I had I
founded my business with andreessen
horowitz money no one's like yeah I
funded my business with this Visa card
but I have the same credit card that you
use to buy that stuff yeah I don't have
it anymore but what a great card I mean
so you launch like you know you get
these samples you've got six watches you
launched on IndieGoGo that's how you
sort of get the business started yeah so
so back then it you know I think I
needed some I mean I knew I needed a
source to to you know Drive orders I
knew I needed capital to continue to go
forward we needed at least like 15 grand
to actually place the first pio so so it
was like okay we need at least 15 grand
and and that was that was the small goal
that was like if we do that we may just
give the money back because yeah is it
really worth it and then of the day to
you know move for a week so we ended up
doing like 15k the first I don't know 30
days of the campaign it was a 50 day
campaign and then and based off of like
IndieGoGo at the time their algorithms
etc we got featured on the homepage and
then went from we did another 30 K that
day and then just filed off ending
around 300 K in pre-orders gotcha so
your mentality was look if we only get
15 K in sales over 50 days we're just
gonna cancel this whole project give
everyone their money back and go do
something else
cuz that's just not where the business
but potentially it was like it does this
even back out yeah so you do 15 K the
first 30 days and IndieGoGo features you
on the home page and you get another 30
K as a result yep and that's that which
are going on
were you in touch with them to get them
to feature you or did they just like
their algorithm was like these guys
should get a home page for today no so
that was that was you know we again
being kind of dropouts in college we
were or dropouts of college we were just
kind of studying the platform yeah we
knew that we knew that like there was
algorithms that we had kind of figured
out how they worked and some of them was
like you know as the campaign is ending
it gets pushed to the top of a page or
you know if a campaign gets a certain
amount of funding percentage-wise they
get pushed if you send enough there's
all these hacks like I was big the word
growth talked to me back then was like I
mean that was like I loved and breathed
that right it was like that's what I
lived by today growth hacking isn't
always scalable to some degrees it can
be but like at some point it was like
okay I need to figure out different ways
to scale the business for back then
grows out I was a growth hacker yeah I
mean it's still like it works when
you're going from like zero to one right
it doesn't work when you're going from
fifty million hundred million like
there's no tiny growth happening
you figured out we like back in 2002
third mm yeah so in 2013 they exist I
think they still exist in 2020 yeah
that'll get you from like you know
fifteen thousand and thirty thousand or
fifteen thousand percent our use are you
really running paid like you know today
when people run Kickstarter campaigns
and I see a bunch of Facebook ads saying
hey go check out this Kickstarter
campaign and were you running paid ads
behind this IndieGoGo campaign was this
all organic back then it was large that
we were paying certain publishers
certain like blogs to post about us so
we had blogs like cool material and then
I basically I again found a some sort of
software that was allowed me to kind of
reach out to editors basically it
aggregated I type in the topic at
aggregate articles across the web and
then it gave me the editors email and I
exported him to an excel and sent a
personal email with their name
everything so tooth to tooth to 200
people I ended up getting 15
or something of them the post about it
which was great playboy was one of them
I was like okay I'll take it whatever
and and then those gave us kind of
momentum and that combination with like
kind of a few other strategies read it
was a big one we we were banned from
reddit actually we got kicked off a
reddit there's I created about a hundred
different reddit accounts we had a proxy
which hides your IP address so we would
log in using different IP addresses
posting without different IP addresses
and then upvote and then you gain
momentum and then once he got in
implementing you just skyrocket
they call that astroturfing one of the
subreddits we did was called shut up and
take my money so it was literally hey
here's a product I want these are
consumers who are looking to buy
something yeah and somehow the
detectives have read it traced back
something yeah there's a thread
somewhere it's great and has a ton of up
boats but there's a thread about how we
movement Astroturf thread it and so now
there's a love-hate relationship I have
with reddit but anyways that was I don't
know if you can still do that today but
that was like a big piece of like
organic traffic basically this is back
when you're still running an IndieGoGo
campaign you're you're trying to get
ready to post about you guys so people
will click over to IndieGoGo and start
funding pretty much up do you think it
was still like a viable launch strategy
today like I feel like in 2013 everyone
was talking about like I go to
Kickstarter once a week and sort of look
at the new projects
I feel like now a bunch of people been
burned by King starter and probably
IndieGoGo because they're just like I
placed an order for something I ordered
a case for my iPhone X or my iPhone 10
it didn't get it didn't get shipped to
me until the iPhone 11 came out and now
this is your IndieGoGo and Kickstarter
as big as they were back then or like
how do you feel about that yeah I don't
think you have like the big the big big
winners at least that I know of
otherwise because I don't hear about him
anymore right and people have been
burned by like the coolest cooler and
stuff like yeah ship but what I would
say is like you know I would rather than
looking at us as like you know an
example of how we did it right that was
2013 and as we know like technology and
the world changes so quickly I would go
and find people who have successfully
funded in the last
you know 12 to 18 months and if they've
done it then I would say that there
could be an argument to still maybe go
get friends and family money or maybe
before you even go out and do that it
just use it as like a platform to get
cuz regardless there's still millions of
people that are using any gogo and
Kickstarter yeah so regardless there's
still an opportunity to get you know
your product in front of faces for
generally free so I'd argue like it's a
good marketing tool whether you raise
300 K or you raise 50 K or 20 it's
theirs I still think there could be a
benefit to it now with Facebook and
everything else I don't know how like
you know the market that got the
marketing stack and how it integrates
with with IndieGoGo or Kickstarter but I
would again if I were starting over I
would look at someone who's recently
funded and just kind of reverse I mean
worse engineering again growth hacking
reverse engineering those are the two
things like I take a brand and just
completely reverse-engineer IndieGoGo
reverse engineer so yeah I would do this
gotcha
okay so you think that they're still
viable strategies well did you realize
once you were on ad to go that you had
found a product that was gonna be big
and scale or did it take some more time
like you know with Native in the first
two months like we were seeing a cost of
customer acquisition of under $2 for the
first two months and I was just like
this business is gonna work I don't have
the plug I haven't made the product yet
that's great enough to drive this
tribest business but I know this
business is gonna work because people
are buying this stuff at $2 like it cost
me $2 in advertising to sell this
product like that's phenomenal
like it doesn't happen today I knew
instantly that the business would work
and it took me a little bit of time to
reformulate the product and really get
my product market fit and see a ton of
growth when did you know that movement
watches is gonna work did you like was
it the day you're on the homepage from
you just did another $15,000 it's
great or did it take some more
time yeah I think there's different
levels of what what's working right I
think yeah when we did when we got on
the homepage at that 30k in a day I said
okay this is this is real now that's
real money this is real let's think
about this but then you know you have
your cube for holiday you know numbers
you start seeing what you remember there
was a day where we had like a $25,000
you know day and that for at that time
it was like holy that's huge and
we've skin
since then but like there's just there's
just you have days I'd and and every
each time you're like you're just really
a ting like even what you're thinking
about it and like the expansion of kind
of where your business can go yeah you
know campaigns over you realize hey look
we're gonna start this business we're
definitely not refunding people's money
we're gonna actually ship this product
we want to make it look what are the
Jimmy operational you know when we
launch native the first time we placed
we we were supposed to pick up stuff
that our manufacturer we used a freight
forwarder to like drive a truck there
and pick it up they were supposed to
arrive on a like a Tuesday they didn't
come on Wednesday did in come on
Thursday I got dispatched another
company gonna pick up the deodorant so
we had our amount of manufacturer and
the first guy picked them up and we'd
already cancel that order so I was like
wait are Germans are on a truck as like
is this manufacturing just long time
supposed to get all these deodorants and
to run the wrong truck and I was like
holy what the is happening do
you guys have any of those operational
because you guys aren't making it stuff
in the United States or are you making
in the US
no we're making it now we're making it
overseas in Asia have you dealt with
Asian you know manufacturers and
shipping things on boats or air freight
like are there operational challenges
right out of the gate yeah I mean I
think they're just a learning curve I
think more than anything we had a three
PL so we had a third party you know kind
of helping us with our fulfillment and
they they took on a lot of like the
logistical kind of stuff in terms of
kind of importing I think I think they
might have even been the importer of
record if I'm not mistaken but you know
was a long time ago I don't remember us
having anything that was like a major
issue per se fortunately but it was more
of just a learning curve and figuring
out you know what what the best way to
do it what the most affordable way to do
it I think a lot of times you just pay a
premium because you don't know better
and then it's we ended up starting to
ship ship bibo and then you have to you
know kind of build that into kind of
your timeline and then you also hear
like you know well is the condensation
like while going over the ocean like
ruin the the watches in the boxes so
there's just a lot of like logistical
thing
you have to keep in mind and think about
but we've never really had a major you
know stopping block or yeah exactly yeah
was it difficult in finding the
manufacturer like I would imagine
or was it look was that easy look you
just go to you know the sheds in
whatever fared they're like okay there's
four hundred watch manufacturers or is
it like really hard to find that kind
you know you could you certainly could
go to like a fair and manufacturers
again we thinking of flying to China for
us when we were just getting started to
get some something sampled I didn't have
the credit card credit to do that so we
ended up we ended up going on Google and
doing some research and finding a
manufacturer that kind of or consultant
who knew different manufacturers and we
worked with him initially and then I
think once you really start to get going
like once our indiegogo attention then
you have other manufacturers who may be
a little bit more legitimate a little
bit more reputable start reaching out
and I don't think it was until err maybe
almost our third year maybe our second
year where we actually flew to China and
met with different manufacturers and in
the watch world there's like middlemen
so like for us we have we're not
middleman but we have a the movements
inside of our watches you know we have a
quartz my o2 movement from uh super
watches so my Oda it's there in most
like quartz watches so they're
incentivized to go and introduce us to
the best manufacturer so they went and
kind of you know pulled us into the
three top manufacturers and kind of got
a see who was vibing with our business
at the time and who believed in us and
and and kind of went from there and if
you had to switch to manufacturers since
you started the business like from that
IndieGoGo campaign to today have you
been like I went from here I still not
be on this facility so I went to you or
you still with the same guy yeah so we
have no we're not with the original we
have multiple manufacturers you know
prior to move on the bottom acquisition
we had multiple manufacturers I think
for multiple reasons
you know some manufacturers are better
at Purdue you're saying you know
different things I think it's always
great to you know whether you want to
leverage them against each other not to
be not to not to bully them but just
simply to make sure that they're being
giving you the best price and so there's
like there's there's benefits to that
you know some some manufacturers can
only do a certain amount of production
and so just it's keeping them you know
responsible for you know what they're
doing and motivated so that they don't
take advantage of you in any way post
Movado I'm not ready to talk about this
have you moved manufacturing in-house
like is Nevada doing a manufacturing or
are you sort of stone all doing the same
thing to do more with your own
independent contractor so no we're still
doing the same Amana there's you know
they do Swiss and etc but I'm pretty
sure that for us at least we we have
still third parties and I think largely
the the the you know fashion watch
industry courts you know movement is all
you I don't think it really makes sense
to go and yeah open up your own fact
release to my knowledge so okay so
you're launching a brand its 2013
IndieGoGo campaign successful look what
is it what is your revenue look like in
2014 you know six years ago or 2015 yes
a year so the first three years I went
so first year we ended at about a
million with including the the IndieGoGo
yeah and I don't think we did much it
was like blogs it was uncrate you know
we were paid the money I spent was like
get on Craig uncle material you know
figure out you know those type of things
more so than rev-share to developing
commission type of opportunities so it
was pretty organic which was great so
you're not we weren't paying for unquote
you were like hey I'm Craig we'll give
you 15% of sales
no no uncrate there's a few so a few
publishers I'm Craig you pay you know
Aflac then it was like seventy five
hundred bucks for a feature but it would
return
you know largely a large amount of
orders so those are like big
opportunities that no longer exist but
also they were like unknown
opportunities so it's kind of navigating
a sea that no one knew like where to go
it's growth exactly so net so that so
now it's a little bit more everyone is
look knows and has seen you know us for
me undies are you guys on all these
blogs so it's it's saturated and it
doesn't just business and perform like
it once did but it was largely blogs and
and and then some was working on it as
well we did a big like refer-a-friend we
really really encourage our our team to
or another team but our customers to
refer their friends for
credit or discounts and then one of the
biggest things we did back then was like
every 500 likes on Facebook we did we
gave away a free watch and then it got
too much so we did a thousand and that
was our fastest growing platform
Facebook and that was just you know we
were like okay we have 500 new people to
like us yeah there's at least one
person's buying a watch from that it's
worth giving out a watch and people just
went nuts about that and we just scaled
through that so that was that was your
one your two we started to play with
Facebook YouTube we did seven million
and that that was like the rocket ship
is where I think we were getting like
$10 cpas for a hundred dollar watch and
that was when it just they just took off
and then so yeah three we did thirty is
2014 yeah so year one year one was a
million to seven to thirty to thirty and
it goes from blog to Facebook to more
Facebook blog to Facebook to a lot more
Facebook and then after probably thirty
it was like how do we diversify
different acquisition channels we don't
want to be solely bet on on Facebook
what if we get saturated what if CPMs go
up uh blah blah here we are today yeah I
remember when we were like the first
time they did raise money we went to
like one of our investors was putting on
some sort of like marketing Day show and
we went there and there were Facebook
reps and they're like yeah on Instagram
we're allowing certain vendors or like
certain businesses to advertise and one
of the first businesses and I was like
how the did you guys know do you
know that like you were one of the first
businesses that get special access I
think we did know that we so back in the
day I was like I mean I was running it
out the gay and then we worked with kind
of a freelance consultant and then we
ended up hiring in-house but it was like
you know anytime there was a beta
because we saw the success and I knew I
knew Instagram was going to be huge
because I used it as a consumer and the
numbers of its growth so we were like
get us on the beta get us on the beta I
was we were really lucky for two reasons
there was we worked right next to the
the Facebook LA office so we basically
just kind of bear-hug Facebook and like
we made sure that that was like a
network that we'd stay
close to and I'm friendly with a bunch
of people over there just in the sense
of like you know not not that we were
getting necessarily special kind of you
know special service but it was just
being able to talk to them more
frequently about what was going on
before we had like a small business rep
in Texas and that was just you hear from
him once a month and it just it was like
you know surface level stuff so yeah it
is weird that like Facebook is sort of
outsourced so many of your
representatives like I think it's an
Austin and they're like you know even if
you're spending you know ten million
dollars a year they're like here's some
rep in Austin that like I'm gonna give
you great great feedback you really have
to network your way within Facebook in
order to get the right people under
account yeah definitely I think they're
I think they're doing the better job but
I don't know I mean we've been we've
been we bit we're now leg and we're
close to them so we've been in the
network so maybe we've been you know
working with certain teams just because
of that but we also have spent as you
guys I'm sure a significant amount of
money on Facebook so yeah yeah once we
were a part of PMG base on PNG Rapstar
account and so like you know we were no
longer yeah so I'm not sure what's
happening last to you yeah they have
different they have I know they have
different set there's like a growth like
a like it's like a growth so it's like
brands that are in the ten millions Plus
and spending you know millions on
Facebook and then you have like yeah
like the the big guys who are you know
big Forbes whether it's exactly exactly
yeah and look you know you guys never
raised a dollar you guys are funding
this on credit cards and then once you
sort of hit that 7 billion dollar range
I'm sure you're profitable or breakeven
and sort of fund a you know did you ever
did you ever think that you should raise
money did you ever try and raise money
or were you like no this business is
working I want to control our own
destiny let's keep it all out yeah I
mean there was there's always a an
internal kind of discussion at me and
Kramer my co-founder had about do we
raise money why would we raise money
everyone else is raising money why are
they raising money does it make sense
like do we need to grow faster than
we're growing and and you know there was
a time when we were strongly considering
at a later stage to go and raise money
to help kind of with expansion and
growth and you know that and
that you know fortunately for us it was
kind of right around the time when we
started talking with Movado
and that just made so much more sense
for us base you know the the synergies
in terms of brand and and just like you
know where we wanted to go they already
largely knew when what we're able to
support and help us so that made more
sense than doing it ourselves and
raising capital and deluding ourselves
but it was tough I think back then the
dialogue wasn't as it wasn't as there
wasn't you know guys like me and you and
others who were talking about like you
know state staylene you know look what
happened and there wasn't examples of
the bonobos in and you know I can't even
think what's other companies that just
there's brand lists there's a what was
the one that just came out the other day
anyways yeah Cass look at Casper's IPO
right yeah 400 million they raise four
hundred million dollars yeah yeah look
there's a ton of this company we work a
brand blue aprons a great example there
anyways probably more more so more of
them than less of them right like I've
turned out to be failures unfortunately
and largely not not because they're
necessary about business just as they
raised that it crazy multiple that they
can't you know kind of get you know run
from so anyways that wasn't as apparent
and we just kind of like we networked
with a lot of people and that was the
one thing because we didn't go to
business school I wouldn't say that like
from the finance side of it like that's
not where our specialty is we were like
bran builders and scrappy and
entrepreneurs and kind of seizing
opportunities and and you know enjoying
the process so we talked to a lot of
different founders to to had raised
money and to be frank like a lot of them
were kind of not happy and said stay
away stay away and it was just weird
that every time we talked to someone who
we idolized in terms of the business
that is yeah all over the news and gets
all the press would be like don't do it
if you don't need if you're making money
don't do it Bubba blah and now I mean I
think that just makes so much sense for
so many reasons and you know from from
and we talked about this even you know
offline all the time but it's just like
in terms of brands being able to acquire
you for for a you know reasonable number
like the second you go and raise money
you may out email price yourself for so
many you know brands and you just cause
complications for you know you may be
growing an unhealthy business which will
hurt
you in Milan yes but there's a day that
that all sort of comes back and haunts
you right like you could rate you could
be celebrating I mean like yeah we just
raised it you know I I think I mentioned
you before II when we were raising money
and we talked to a fund they're like
we'll put in three million dollars at a
30 million dollar valuation or 30
million in a few million dollar value
pair so I was like I could get a 30
million dollar valuation for 300 from
this person sitting across the devil
from me right yeah look that doesn't
make sense
they they're very honest about it
they're like looking 300 you're gonna
have to work here for five more years
and build a 600 and I was like that's I
was like five to ten years I have no
idea what the world is gonna look like
five or ten years from now I don't know
if I've the capacity to work that luck
you know I don't know if I can maintain
this 800 million dollar business and the
three million dollars just doesn't seem
that interesting yeah you know what's
crazy is now I also like when you're
looking when you're starting to look at
companies when I see a bunch of ads like
in the subways of New York City or on
Billboard's I'm just like I don't know
if that no longer like holy that
brand is awesome when I see stones
happening at the end of quarters like at
the end of March or at the end of June
I'm just like these guys are looking to
me quarterly numbers that they're you
know that are that are required by their
board yeah and so he's seeing how
businesses are sort of building
themselves specifically because they
raise a ton of outside capital instead
of trying to focus on building the best
pasilla and I feel like the reason might
be and and I'm not sure about this but
like you know I think that the VCS who
had a lot of experience in tech like
tech needs capital often right not only
is it not always as much capital as some
of these tech companies have received I
was just looking at Shopify I think
they've only raised four before kind of
before they went public it only raises
like 130 million or something like that
which isn't really a time honey
any gray is like 60 and so Shopify is
now worth seventy four billion dollars
raised at like a 300 400 million
evaluation and honey I think race sixty
million and sold for four billion so
even those companies honey raised less
money than like Casper above us or
guys which-which again it's like I think
it's just because VCS wanted scale they
wanted growth versus having a healthy
brand really focusing on a consumer and
like if it's resonating it's resonating
you can't force it and I think that
that's where people got you know people
can you can force people to buy someone
you can spend a lot of money you spend a
thousand dollars for something to buy a
watch if you bought it right like that's
possible to do but it doesn't back out
and that's what they were doing on you
know blue apron or Casper and etc and
and now the mentality has shifted I mean
I hear it just from like my network that
like you sees are looking for more
profitable businesses and they're you
know it's it's it's a total mind shift
and it's funny because like back in the
day I remember talking to some of the
bigger like bigger funds and just just
networking not even looking to raise but
we talked about our business and kind of
get laughs that it's like not I'd left
that like it's just not it's not a real
business it's not gonna be can't scale
this business blah blah blah and so I
don't know I wrote this article recently
his name was and he's like the reason
that glossier and a way of working is
because they don't have any competition
as opposed to like the caspere's of the
world that have a ton of competition and
I'm like are you insane
you think a way doesn't have any
competition in luck of course
they're just like less competition I'm
like they do a great job with branding
they do a great job with marketing and
they're out hustling people building and
and like being operationally efficient
as opposed to the casters of the world
that weren't operationally efficient and
burned a ton of money yeah it is insane
how DC's don't get direct-to-consumer
even though it's been around for so long
and it puts so much money into it yeah I
think they're I think you're building
yeah right I think and I hope that
they're starting to in it and and
they're you know I think it maybe not
the biggest ones because they're looking
for big opportunities but some of some
smaller you know VCS are look are happy
with the smaller exit right like yeah
they're okay with that but I think the B
C's that we were talking to back in the
day are you know have huge funds with
with businesses like snapchat and so
forth and it's a big it
they want a billion dollar evaluation
type of a billion dollar exit is kind of
what they want when you think about it
so did you like had that mind that might
have already shifted by the time or was
that still like I feel like that's a
pretty new mind I'm not even sure like
you sold the business in 2018 I'm not
sure that might exist in 2018 I sold my
business in 2017 I'm positive it didn't
exist in 2017 in 2017 people are like
why are you selling your business why do
you raise more money and really grow
this thing I was like we're doing tens
of millions of dollars in revenue we're
doing a million dollars in EBIT a month
at this point like it is a real
business and I don't know how much
longer I can keep continued its growth
trajectory and I'm not sure I can do it
by myself you know had that mind shift
mindset shift into profitability by the
time you sold your business or was that
still a year away I mean sorry thing
were we always profitable are you saying
just no no I'm saying DC's DC started
thinking about profitability in I
actually think one of the big or bigger
articles that came out I think you were
in it as well jason delray from yeah I
don't know what a publication
yeah yeah recode yeah yeah and he
published and it was like me you too big
acquisitions who and he kind of the
writing on the whiteboard shadows and I
think it might have been least as well
he goes these companies you know either
raise very little or are profitable and
you're seeing acquisitions successful
everyone's successful in that position
right employees get money we get money
like the you know the choir is happy
like it's across the board it's a good
acquisition and he kind of says is this
the future and I think that was probably
right around 2018 and I think you
started to see a shift when but no bus
you know kind of get got we got written
off by by Walmart and you start to just
see kind of a trend across the the the
kind of industry but yet your point I
don't think it was I don't think it was
adopted
you know widely until probably more
recently than ever yeah yeah the talk
didn't you know folks that he mentioned
that article yeah anybody okay let's go
back a little bit more to like movements
growth you know from one seven thirty
you're focusing on Facebook you
diversify
acquisition you know I've seen you and
Cramer on television more than I've seen
like no guarantee basically you know
sometimes I watch TV and during
commercials I'm just like I recognize Oh
first stores are all consumers towards
building pop-ups on TV it's just direct
one time I saw you I think I saw like
maybe Hubble contacts yeah and then me
and I was like okay it's just us now I
know some of the channels you know
Instagram like influencers would like I
think it was a Kim Kardashian at one
point I've seen you run TV ads where are
you spending money you know today over
the last couple of years and how do
those things that like you know does TVs
still back out does it look do you know
a native we never could afford
influencer ads with Kim Kardashian's
like major celebrities do those things
back out or is it like Alert sort of
test and learn process we were
influencers I don't know if there's a
Yelp that's good that's actually a great
question I know there is definitely
databases full of like you know ability
to reach out and give him formation and
feedback and engagement metrics so but
in terms of like you know how was the
experience in the back out like did they
do they work with you well like it
didn't really yeah at least didn't when
we were doing it our first the biggest
one was Kylie Jenner for us that was
like early early on and that was back in
the day we're like you know a lot of
Instagram influencer marketing was
backing out especially people like like
Kylie who this was like yeah maybe it
was 2015
that we did it maybe 16 so it was early
on in the company today though it's
spread out I mean you know we still do
Facebook we do still do TV podcasts
Instagram obviously I think we might
still do some Pinterest and we've tested
it anything from like snapchat we've
done tabouleh back in the day so it's
really like I mean ah I guess my
strategy was you know you want to you
want to figure out the right marketing
mix
and test into it any of an influencer
you have like different tears right you
have the kylie jenner's of the world and
then you have people who maybe have 10
million or less who are who are
influencers but that's that's kind of
their their their getting product and
that's kind of their main source of
revenue or their a fashion you know or
youtuber and then you have maybe below a
hundred thousand or somewhere around
there may be five hundred thousand who
could be micro right yeah so we so
there's like we're always testing we're
always trying to figure out well you
know where are we spending the most
efficient dollar is it doesn't make
sense
our you know is that is the amount of
sales that we're getting in one channel
like the incremental revenue we're
getting they're like what does that
actually equate to and so we're just
trying to figure out like we're always
testing and that's what we've kind of
built that in-house and that's yeah I
think what's made us special is that you
know if there is a marketing channel
that comes around like we can identify
it and apply kind of our methodology to
it in it and it's a very agile
you know methodology versus just you
know buying TV even though buying TV the
way that we probably do versus buying
kind of national broadcast is different
but it's a little like buying on
Facebook or buying on tabouleh or
snapchat any of those or Google or very
or more or more similar I'd say than
buying kind of paid media yeah it's
crazy like marketing is really a living
organism like you can't be like okay
Facebook works it's gonna work for me
for her you have to like diversify and
like maybe Google works for ear and then
it doesn't I remember snapchat worked
for us for a while didn't work for us
after that yeah but you really have to
diversify those marketing channels
pretty quickly and like constantly be
testing them to be like it's a working
hour if not even Facebook but you know
which has been look Facebook has been a
behemoth obviously in digital
advertising probably since 2014 today
Facebook is like right now Facebook is
very different than oh my you know two
months ago like if you talked to like
Facebook just returning earlier today
and they're like you know we're not in
from advertising cuts you know Expedia
that a CEO of Expedia was like we spent
five billion dollars a year on
advertising usually
this year we're gonna spend 1 billion
and we've already spent a ton of that
it's because like you know kovetz going
on and so these began crisis have come
down yeah I wanted omen
influence our advertising because I feel
like you guys were one of the earliest
guys to do that you talk about 2015 2016
is it just a lot of like well one can
you talk about the most you ever paid an
influencer like well I'm curious what is
the most you've ever paid it was
definitely in this it was it was
somewhere around for a single post it
was close to like yeah like $150,000
okay yeah maybe but that was early on
and yeah that was a that was again
different I'm like I don't think that we
certainly want to do that today unless
it was like you know there was someone
who's we're gonna be ongoing working
with the brand or you know collab or
whatever the case may be but so yeah
that was that's a big chunk of change
why would you do that today is it
because they're like the numbers we're
backing out in 2015 and don't
necessarily back out look in 2015 people
saw that they were like what is this I
want to engage with this while in 2020
they're like this is an ad by this
influencer or something yeah I think I
think it's a combination of all the
right like back then it was first off
the engagement wasn't you know repressed
they you could so you were getting more
engagement you're getting you know more
impressions right if she had 50 million
followers or whatever it was back then
you know majority of those people
probably saw it
Facebook was you know the post four
chronological or whatever it was and you
so that was that and then also just she
wasn't posting a ton of ads right she
wasn't Oracle you know collaboration so
I don't even know if she was posting
much about her own stuff at the time so
this was just it was just the right time
right place and I think today even
remove her you know any huge person you
know with 50 million or more followers
like I just don't I don't think the
engagements there like people just
aren't seeing the post as much as they
once were and even if they do they're
just I mean it's it we're just we're
just you know used to it by now to see
you know unfortunately you know it adds
you know they're just even if they're
even if they're you know as authentic as
possible and they really use the product
and they love the product unless they
really back something personally and are
like you know they're they're a partner
like I just don't necessarily see it
backing out like it once did so but you
know there's arbitrage elsewhere always
right like maybe you take stalks that
next place
maybe twitch right which is a big place
that we're trying to figure out
especially with those blue light
blocking glasses like yeah you know the
gamers are farther it screens yeah and
they have I mean we you've seen like the
trends about the ninja ninja gamer and
then there's a bunch of them that
honestly I feel like the average person
doesn't know much about but it's this
underground world that's just absolutely
booming yeah are you already advertising
and take talk right now I don't know
that we're do we have a tick tock
account we're creating videos we're
playing with it I created I finally
created a tick tock just to figure it
out I've now I now understand how
something can get the amount of views it
does and I don't know if it's all 100%
authentic but nonetheless people are
seeing it there's there's a lot more
opportunity for the average person or or
to growth act let's call it tick tock
then there is Instagram today in my
opinion I think you can get a lot more
impressions on tick tock for free and I
see them doing some paid stuff and the
great thing about their paid stuff which
I don't think we've gone into yet but
they're paid stuff looks very it looks
like a regular post so yeah you have to
almost double take and it's there it
says if you have to double taking oh
that's an ad so they do a great job
their ad units is what we call them or
her you know really gray but we are
doing some stuff on Twitch but that's
not that's I don't think we're actually
paying like twitch commercials as much
as we're working with individuals on
Twitch kind of yeah does any marketing
channel represent more than like 25
percent of your marketing spent like its
Facebook more than 25 percent are
influencers I think Facebook still the
majority uh still the majority yeah but
just I feel like it's pretty common for
most e-commerce friends but yeah I mean
Facebook is just like so good at what
they do
yeah we can create demand yeah and the
better the better that you do at
Facebook the better that you are at
Facebook the the you know you get more
learnings from like what creatives
working what ad units working your
certain audiences so just I mean you ran
it yourself right for so long as well so
it's just I think it's it's yeah it's
the
the scary thing is when you get too deep
in it and and Facebook starts dictating
you know your your business a little bit
based off of like what's selling on
Facebook too much and you become reliant
on oh well this ads working for this
specific you know watch or the specific
you know sense of deodorant and yeah
it's not necessarily working so it's a
balance of like is it the ad is it so
there's there's there's a I don't know
it's it's it's still relatively new you
know comparison the TV or anything else
so yeah yeah I mean it's both native
it's both our greatest strengths and our
greatest weakness
like we were great at it it was minting
us a ton of money and it was scary as
hell because what does this change what
he longed to do categories are they
gonna go as well as deodorant in yeah
he's really terrifying are you guys more
male or female focus I have to imagine
male we launched it a few years female I
think maybe 2016 show so about four
years now but it's it's actually closer
it's actually closer to 5050 now I think
in terms of product if I'm not mistaken
we have a look we have a lot of female
buyers who buy for you know whether it's
you know boyfriends or whatever that you
know the case may be so it's yeah
watches and it watches even sunglasses
or can be you know great gifting items
so we do get a lot of gifting I don't
know I don't know if I don't have
deodorant as much a gifting it's
actually more than like q4 is our
slowest quarter yeah like you know we
are able to say hey this pack of like
you know healthy freedom products yeah
it works I mean it's not as good as
surprisingly okay and or watch it's
still the majority of your business
right now I would have to imagine
sunglass watches are still majority
sunglasses law I'm just kind of
secondary so sunglasses and if you if
you combine sunglasses never scrolls
they're definitely you know a growing
kind of segment of the business but
watches are still the majority
okay let's fast-forward to 2018 you're
now talking to Movado what is the firt
like is the first conversation with
Movado face-to-face is it like it's like
email is it like when the first time
you've met them face to face is in LA or
wherever they are I have no idea time we
met them and I think they came to us I
want to say we I think they came to us
we we had met with them or no we had
talked to them we had a kind of a mutual
contact we had talked to the CEO you
know years before just more so just you
know again I think you just want to if
there if there's a way to work together
one day partner if there's a way that
you know just just keep the dialogue
open like you know here's what here's
who we are and what we're doing and then
we ended up kind of getting in contact
when we were you know contemplating it
do we raise or yeah you know what's
what's the case and maybe there's an
opportunity to work together or partner
and they were interesting interested in
acquiring us and and then it was like
well okay is that the right thing for us
movement the company the employees and
and then as we you know went further
we're just like this makes so much sense
they have you know infrastructure that
again complements like what we do today
what we where we want to go in the
future they have experience in you know
obviously manufacturing and other
categories so I think they came out to
us if I'm not mistaken either they came
up to us or we went to them because I
think it was it was supposed to you know
we needed to make sure that people
didn't see us you know meeting their
employees or our employees so so they
definitely didn't just come in the
office out the gate if I imagine
correctly I think it was it was like
initial kind of meaning somewhere
off-site and then I can't remember where
it was a little bit there in New Jersey
yes there in New Jersey and then they
have an office in New York as well
gotcha
how often they evolve they have offices
all over the world actually and I
believe in Switzerland as well and well
before all of this I was probably was
out there too often maybe like three or
four times a year which wasn't which
wasn't too bad and then that we make a
trip like last year I went to Dubai
for a big conference in Switzerland for
a big conference so yeah it wasn't it
wasn't all that it wasn't too much but
definitely yeah I had never been New
Jersey beforehand so this was you know
four times in year after it was and the
vibes a little I now have my favorite
hotel restaurant you know oh here's this
uber driver that I recognize again
process you know can you tell me a
little bit about you know what is going
on through your head as well like you
know when you're when you haven't raised
any money but you know and you're you in
credit card debt when you started a
business by the end is the number that
you sold for public were not public the
number we sold for it was public so it's
can you imagine can you talk about that
Network yes it was a hundred million
dollars and then there was one million
dollars and then there was like an earn
a component but for us the process took
about like 75 days I believe from like
initial kind of conversation so what
went fast because yeah again we were
contemplating well do we raise money
what do we do and yeah and this was you
know we I mean everyone wanted to move
fast so it was like a 75 day process of
from initial I think phone call to you
know you you know hired you know banks
to kind of help you with the process and
then you meet you know these parties
meet and then there's due diligence kind
of that they go through on your end and
and then it's just kind of figuring out
you know any questions that have
essentially because they need to be
comfortable with you know the business
and questions as well so and were you
comfortable I'm sorry do you think that
the relationship that you had had for a
few years these guys was helpful for us
I never had a relationship with P&G
or almost nearly any of the guys who
were talking to us until we were selling
the business was your relationship with
Movado you know that was built up over
time important to that or do you think
it would have happened anyway I think it
was important we didn't have we didn't
have it's not like I hadn't you know met
or talked to them much so it was like
you know it was just
an introduction that kept us top of mind
it's a more superficial relationship
yeah yeah yeah and I'd say that you know
I'd say that I would recommend for
entrepreneurs if they have if they know
who like a strategic is that they think
that you know they could get acquired by
and complement that business and help
that business and vice versa I think
it's worth you know figuring out a way
to get in touch with that person and you
know you know you obviously you're
always scared cuz it's competition like
they could acquire you or they could you
know they're all these companies are big
enough to go and start their own version
of it right so you you want to you know
you want to just have a conversation
it's like you kind of you know dance
around a little bit and be you know you
want to create an authentic relationship
without sharing too much of the business
but sure you know he was he was always
that you know again he was a great you
know the conversation we had with him
was really great it was just you know an
introduction time who we were what her
story was dropped you know kind of what
we're doing now it was really just
interested in who we are what we were
doing and wasn't trying to like you know
get information or anything that was
just a very and we had conversations
with different people over the years and
I actually have friends again who are in
certain businesses who make it a point
to be really friendly with like Sur and
they send them product unsolicited with
a note right like and they in it and it
could you know I think I think I mean
we're all humans right I think if you
get for some people who are really
trying to reverse engineer that exit
like I think yeah if you have a
relationship with someone who is in the
driver's seat of making that decision
and they're familiar with your business
it's going to get them more excited
about the business so versus just having
no clue and then one day getting a call
saying hey this is my business like it's
at that point it's probably too late so
I do think it's probably a good idea
that you know
yeah it's sometimes it works out yeah
yeah absolutely and like this personal
relationships are so important I
remember like you know getting along
with somebody who you might work for or
work with it's so I remember when you're
trying sell native there was a guy that
we were chatting with and he's like I
can tell you're not serious about
selling native online how could you pop
loose that we're doing tens of millions
of dollars in revenue millions of
dollars in Ubud ah he's like because you
don't own native
come and I was just like I don't know I
was just like you don't know what you're
talking about and this is like the CEO
of that company and we're sitting around
like a dinner table probably 10 people
and 15 people his senior executives are
my bankers and I'm like you don't know
what you're talking about
it's like there's just silence in the
room yeah I was just like you have no
idea what the you're doing with
e-commerce silence and just like and
like afterwards our banker the bankers
and I would sort of just walking around
San Francisco he's like that was the
banker was like that was a really
awkward conversation and I was like yeah
I don't know what else to say this guy
doesn't know what the he's talking
about when it comes to e-commerce he's
totally he has no business in cars
he's trying to tell me about my injury
I'm not trying to tell about his but I
know what he's wrong and it gets me
really excited afterwards I love like
afterwards he takes me out like you know
he and I go to dinner one-on-one and
he's actually great and like he and I
grew up watching like infomercials
feather and that's how we got good at
marketing and I remember like talking
about like the rotisserie chicken and
like the Ron Popeil mystery chicken I
love it I love the guy and I remember
him saying he's like look there are
probably three people I would trust to
take up my business and you're one of
them boys and I was like you know it
sounds like you guys don't get along
good in reality and sort of appreciate
what it takes to be a good owner and I
really enjoyed them but in like those
personal relationships and who you're
gonna work with are so important I
especially post-acquisition right like
that the day you signed the docs it's
great but like you're gonna have to work
with this guy you're still at movement
watches for you of you know it's been a
year and a half since you've got to go
along with that person stuff no
absolutely they get on that so you saw
the business you know all this money you
go from in 2013 be a you know using your
Chase Freedom Card
to now having you know what he's like
you know what do you do with the first
thing you buy what do you do with all
this money I think that was it it takes
time to like settle in and I think for
me at least like trying to figure out
like what what you're supposed to feel
when you you know sell your company
you know it's obviously bittersweet
because that means it's not yours
anymore and and you know like you're
waiting for this day to have you know
kind of have the financial you know
freedom so to speak that you want and
but you're not gonna go immediately and
buy out like it's not like you have a
house lined up to buy tomorrow and even
if you buy a house tomorrow like it
takes another few months to like get
settled in and like I'm 28 years old so
like you know I live by myself so it's
like what do I do I really want to go
buy a house so it's it's and it's
figuring out just like what life's like
and and and taking a breath and not
going in and trying to invest in a bunch
of startups right away so for me it was
like you know I think eventually that my
biggest purchase was you know a condo
that I mean it's a 1500 square foot
condo so it's it's great for just me
right now especially in quarantine but I
did that but yeah it's like you know and
then it for me it's it's like you know
helping my family out and it's figuring
out you know how I'm gonna you know
invest you know the right way and and
and so forth but I think the biggest
balance is just like for me at least and
I mention this a little bit before we
started recording was just kind of like
you know ultimately it's like what makes
me happy was like what I was always in
kind of searched for and like building a
business having a financial a big
financial outcome was like always
something that I thought was something
that was gonna make me happy and and
doing and I think it's a component of it
I don't I think if you're on if you're
unhappy in your life before and you sell
your company it probably is gonna just
magnify those issues even more versus
like I think I was like in a pretty good
spot but this is giving me like I can't
really be complaining about you know my
financial situation so it's just
figuring out like what do I live for
outside of just work and and money like
what are my hobbies or what what makes
what what makes me happy and I think
fortunately that can be my focus right a
large piece of my focus which I'm super
fortunate about but it's it's I think
it's taken a couple years to like and
I'm still working on but it's taking a
couple years to really figure out things
that make me happy and like keep my my
brain kind of you know I'm stimulated
etc what are some of those things
the one I mean the number-one thing and
I think has to come out of just like
working out for me I think that like if
I work out and eat whether it's cardio
anything if I get a good sweat in and I
instantly feel better that day like
whatever I eat later I could eat like
later that day whatever it is at
least I got that workout in and like
yeah you know and was moving and you
just it just you feel better about
yourself it's it's known to give you you
know you're sure you're you know
endorphins etc so I think that's a big
one meditating has been big you know
even if it's ten minutes a day or even a
couple times a week that's been great
you know I think those have been people
I think relationships I really realized
like okay like you know you you have
this financial outcome but like and it
doesn't need to be just like love
relationships but just friends and
general it's like one of my favorite
things is like going on a trip with with
buddies or doing stings for you know my
family whatever it is and it's like
those are things that make me happy so
you know I'm on a road to still figure
out I think my biggest thing in life to
be honest is just to figure out it's a
pursuit of happiness what is it that you
could be happy with 100 K or 50 K you're
like I think that's great that's fine
it's just figuring out what is it that
makes you happy and I think everyone's
kind of in the race to you know make
money because you need it to survive and
and once you have your I think you're
kind of the your life you know your
regular finances you're kind of you know
necessary finances in place I think it's
then figuring out you know the things
that make me happy I'm talking about
working out right like working out
anyone can do and sure and you know
everything else I'm talking about there
are things that people can do so it's
just I'm just I'm fortunate that I'm
able to take a step back and really kind
of focus on it though
yeah we met a few times in person
certainly I think every time we get
brunch in LA I'm always like amazed at
how you know self-conscious you are
about that happiness for me I was always
like okay great being being wealthy is
gonna make me happy no it absolutely
doesn't you're absolutely right and like
I would you know everyone says being
rich doesn't make you happy and I feel
like no one told me as I didn't believe
it yeah you're right it's all about like
what's
inside of you but you happy not
necessarily like it's just yeah and it
makes it easier don't get me wrong like
if you it like if you want to go take a
trip or buy something but like I think I
realized that like having a big TV or
having a nice you know MacBook or iPad
doesn't those things don't don't those
don't make my happiness levels for the
moment I open it I get this joy and then
it's instantly gone pretty much after
that
but like experiences experiences are
like number one yeah I think I think
health mental health you know your body
keeping those like at an all-time high
and then experiences that ultimately
like yeah like you know if I just try
and look back on my life if I died
tomorrow like if I look back on my life
like what would I be upset I didn't
experience or do or experience with
certain people right like I have so many
I think I'm also excited the fact that
like just going through the journey a
movement like these people I've done it
with like you know especially early on
like I have great relationships with
those people I'm like and I want to make
sure that like as people leave or like
you know as the company changes that
like keep I still maintain those
relationships with those people and
that's super important to me as well so
yeah yeah the the people that I worked
with the native or like my best friends
yeah and you're right it's certainly a
life is a lot easier but it is crazy
where you're like man I really want this
thing you end up making a purchasing
decision to get it or you get invited to
this thing that you've always wanted to
get invited to it you never wear and get
invited to and you're just like oh this
is not gonna make me happy and you're
just like I got ya and it's hard to
also like mentally like you know I buy
something and I'm like yeah you're right
moment of joy would you buy it then all
of that is gone instantly and you're
like okay here's this other thing you
know but you have to be like you know
what I think this thing is gonna bring
me two seconds of joy I wasn't worth it
I thought with Justin Khan on Twitter
he's he's like you know
everything he says I'm just like I want
to be like this guy he has a ton he has
a ton of money and he's like I'm trying
not to buy anything cuz i buy this
$10,000 I'm just like afterwards I'm not
happy about it again that's like crazy
that that's so true yeah and it happens
to everybody
yep I did it for the first time I bought
like a really like I bought some
off-white is what I did that was my
let me get let me just see I had to do
it because it and I and I swear to God I
haven't learned it once it's still in my
closet not even because of the krona
just because I was like waiting for the
right time and now it's I'm just like
okay I'll never do that again
so yeah it seems once you have them
you're just like I have no idea why yeah
yeah you know you're like an investor an
advisor at least for a bunch of
direct-to-consumer businesses
I know like Skyler I think is one of
them that's go and I are both in yeah
yeah yeah what do you think happens to
direct your consumer you know Casper
happened you know this darling of the
direct consumer of this that sort of
didn't go anywhere our voices had to do
a recap you know brand 'less went out of
business Cove it happened we work happen
all of a sudden people are focusing on
profitability in the next five years of
direct consumer are people building more
natives and movements or movements in a
where are people still going to the you
know vc-backed outcome or are they just
built like you know what happens in the
next five years I think for GBC
businesses I think it's it's gonna be a
more friends and family like you mean
you may need more capital than a credit
card you know to get it going but I
think people are gonna be you know how
more you know relatively bootstrapped or
you know profitable kind of conscious
businesses and I think it's still very
possible and honestly mostly companies
that I invest in are either they're
either profitable or like very very very
close to it and the only reason they're
not is because they're growing so you
know aggressively etc that it that it
makes sense they're kind of on that that
fence but but yeah I think I think again
I think there will be some interesting
potential businesses that come out of Co
bid that aren't necessarily due to see
or may need that may need capital to
grow and maybe still you know chasing a
big you know exhibit but I think in
terms of like the direct to consumer
brands I think it's I just from what
I've seen the ones that are the
healthiest and an able to I mean this is
a good example this is the most radical
thing that's ever happened right and I
think pretty much our lifetime or
parents lifetime and their parents but
in terms of like who can you know
weather the storm right now are people
who you know I think it's people who
have good businesses that are
profitable and can stay afloat and and
if they need to be more leaning they can
be more lean but if you already if you
already raised at a certain multiple
like the difference between getting back
to that environment you know could take
years to get back versus a bootstrapped
profitable company who maybe it adds
another unit have two years to kind of
your exit or wherever you want to
whatever you wanted to get to but at
least you can you control your business
you maintain things like you stay lean
and it just adds a little bit you know
longer to kind of you know your timeline
which i think is fine and it's not the
end of the world by any means yeah
couldn't agree more with all that all
right really check really appreciate
your time you know you said one of the
things that brings you happiness is
relationships I feel like the first time
you and I met was I forgot we're in
Santa Monica you and I were running
through one of a few bootstrap is mister
or like you were running one of those
and I was trying to become and I always
admired that and like you know
inspiration from the way you built
movement and like every time you and I I
remember unite connect was in all of the
business that you were building it was
in all the way you were thinking about
it I remember when you're thinking about
selling your business you're like I'm
gonna go and like I haven't told my
parents I'm gonna tell my parents super
excited I'm gonna have this financial
safety because of me and I was in awe of
not only the way you were thinking about
about how humble were this relationship
there's one that brings me a ton of
happiness and I love connecting with you
every time we do I feel like you know
you and I are kindred spirits that want
to build profitable businesses if that
are willing to do that that are like you
know independently that like are
independent minded and sort of ignore
the Silicon Valley ecosystem a ton of
money and you know I've had great
outcomes and we're both like happiness
and like I've realized now that
certainly doesn't come from financial
success and I'm trying to figure out you
realize what it is tell me Oh Cheryl
sherry good I could have said it I could
have said a better more yeah please
couldn't have said it better man I
appreciate it it's always been a joy to
- you know hang out and to talk with you
I get insight from you all the time as
well so I totally appreciate it and
thank you so much for having me on this
podcast I haven't done a podcast you
know in a while that I can remember so I
was excited about this one so and wish
you the best of luck with it
[Music]